hey leute was gedacht mach jetzt
willkommen bei einem video ja leute ich
hoffe natürlich gibt es gut heute mal
mit einem nicht unbedingt neuen thema
aber es gibt bald was neues was ich mir
überlegt habe und zwar baut das neue
projekt sozusagen praktisch auf diesem
video auf also ich muss erst dieses
video machen um dann das andere video zu
machen oder so hat ja jetzt
wahrscheinlich am weg schon gelesen
heute geht es noch einmal um 100 prozent
zufällig bestellen und zwar hier für das
heutige video louis vitton rausgesucht
kennt wahrscheinlich jeder von euch ist
eine sehr exklusive teure marke und ja
im online shop von louie vito werden wir
heute zufällig bestellen mal gucken was
wir da so bekommen werden so jetzt ganz
wichtig vorweg alles was ich praktisch
bekomme oder was ich praktisch bestellen
muss werde ich natürlich im endeffekt
nicht bestellen ich meine wenn ich fünf
produkte mir aussuche lande schon bei
7000 euro so das ist ja viel zu viel
geld weil den höchst sachen okay das
kann man auf jeden fall machen 400 200
euro aber ich gebe mich 7000 euro für
irgendeinen krims krams aussehen nicht
im endeffekt ähnlich tragen werde wobei
die hälfte auch noch für frauen ist aber
jetzt gut zuhören teil meines neues
format ist was teil von meinem neuen
format wie du es sein dass ich all die
sachen die ich jetzt zufällig ermitteln
im endeffekt doch für stelle allerdings
alles als fake sachen das heißt in
nächster zeit werden öfter einmal videos
kommen wo ich von bekannten teuren
marken wie zum beispiel louis vuitton
gucci meinetwegen auch supreme oder so
halt fake sachen bestelle alles mögliche
und das euch im video vorstellen wenn
ihr das cool findet last gern noch nach
oben da ja also freut euch darauf und
wir fangen jetzt an mit dem video so wir
befinden uns hier auf der offiziellen
louis vuitton seite man habe ich
kopfhörer drin
um ehrlich zu sein war ich hier selber
noch nie vorher drauf deswegen so genau
einschätzen wie viel das alles kostet
kann ich gar nicht ich habe letztens da
mal einem tuch gekauft das war einfach
hier so ein tuch sonst praktisch für
damen kann man sich so rumhängen hat
glaube ich 450 euro gekostet baden
schlepper auf jeden fall so wir haben
hier oben einmal für damen und für
herren ich würde sagen ich bestell drei
sachen hausherren und drei sachen aus
damen und tue das alles in den warenkorb
ich würde sagen gefangen einfach an mit
herren so jetzt habe ich ihm ein
zufallsgenerator wir würfeln einfach
und haben die neuen das heißt 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 8 9
reisegepäck klicken drauf die haben wir
die 212 horizon kollektionen und jetzt
haben wir schon die ganzen produkte also
okay jetzt wenn man so ein louis vuitton
koffer durch die gegend zieht dass das
sieht schon natürlich cool aus aber so
ein ding kostet zum beispiel der hier
2650 euro ich finde das so krass wie so
machen sage ich mal so populär sind das
ist genug reiche menschen gibt die sich
einfach so ein koffer für 2650 euro
kosten
denn der produktion vielleicht 30 euro
kostet oder so wir nicht mal
wahrscheinlich so wie würfel hier die
einheit ist es auch noch der körper okay
wir haben hier diesem koffer zur auswahl
hinzufügen wurde zu ihrer auswahl
hinzugefügt ja das ist ja nicht so wir
gehen wieder zurück in die herren
kategorie und 10
das war ja gerade die neuen oder 1 2 3 4
5 6 7 8 9 10
fashion shows das brauche ich gar nicht
ich suche irgendwelche sachen ich will
nicht zu einer show hier haben wir die
einst ja sommer 2018 kollektionen hier
haben wir nochmal hier einzel lief
konnte die einst alle kollektionen ok
und jetzt haben wir die elf 123456 hier
guckt euch an wie hässlich dieser schuh
ist 570 euro dieser schule so hässlich
ich würde dafür nicht mal 20 euro
bezahlen es gibt schuhe die sind
deutlich hübscher in diesem stil und
kosten nicht mal 15 euro ja gut so das
war die sechs sieben acht neun und zehn
messenger pm
das ist halt so traurig diese tasche
findet die irgendwer von euch hübsch ich
könnte die tasche echt total hässlich
gut in blau gibt es ja auch noch mal
sehen wie das aussieht ich finde da
brauche aber eigentlich schon besser als
schwarz deswegen fügen wir das einfach
mal zur auswahl hinzu
zwei sachen haben wir jetzt schon im
warenkorb diese messe in der tasche aus
leder wurde von unserer historischen
kongo tasche inspiriert und ist eine
modische und doch diskrete tasche für
den alltag
sie ist mit der klassischen ja super und
wieso kostet das fakten dingen 1710 euro
gut mal sehen was wir noch bekommen
wir haben hier die fünft 12345 ready to
7 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 t shirts polos
wahrscheinlich jetzt ein t shirt für 700
euro so ohne spaß wenn ich mir dieses t
shirt angucke 310 euro würde ich zehn
t-shirts bestellen die aber alle zehn
mal so geil sind wir dieses shirt und
ich wird trotzdem nicht auf 310 euro
kommen egal wir haben jetzt hier die 51
23 445 klassisches t shirt mit 260 euro
kann man auch für zwei euro über amazon
kaufen
ja in welcher farbe nehme ich das nehmen
wir einfach mal grau zur auswahl
hinzufügen gut wurde es wäre aus wenn
hinzugefügt mal ein kleiner
zwischenstand wir haben hier insgesamt
acht gerade mal 4000 620 euro aber
immerhin ist die expresslieferung wenn
man die auswählt einigermaßen okay vom
preis hätte ja sein können dass man da
200 euro nochmal zeit gut wir gehen
jetzt in die damen kategorie jetzt bin
ich mal gespannt ob das teurer ist oder
günstiger können wir dann mal schauen ob
man merkt für die herren bezahlen
theoretisch kann oder für die damen
wir haben jetzt hier die 8 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
8 uhren und schmuck so leute wie die fia
das sind sogar um 12 34 uhr
ich hätte jetzt mit mehr gerechnet
und einmal die sieben einzel 3 4 5 6 und
die 78 2300 euro
das mache ich ja allein mit diesem video
ja gar nix
nein spaß an die eu irgendwas besonderes
hamburger reisen für die neue smart
watch sogar eine smart watch zur auswahl
hinzufügen wurde zu ihrer auswahl
hinzugefügt alles klar vielen dank also
ich bin wirklich sehr gespannt ob ich
all diese sachen als fake bekommen werde
vor allem wo ich die sachen als fake
bekommen werde ob ich das über amazon
bekommen oder sonst wird ihr könnt gerne
mal in die kommentare schreiben
oder mir tipps geht wo man dann solche
sachen her bekommt wo man gut verkaufen
kann vielleicht auch möglichst günstig
und die dann halt region das könnte auf
jeden fall echt ein cooles video werden
so wir haben jetzt hier wieder die damen
kategorie und die 9 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
reisegepäck ja das hatten wir eben schon
mal als wenn ich mir hier gespannt um
die 212 reisen collection die kennen wir
ja schon und der gut hier war ich eben
schon dann nehmen wir doch mal noch mal
von vorne
wir haben hier die fünf damen 12345
ready to wear hatten wir auch schon
neben und hier die 4 1 234 jacken mäntel
das könnte richtig teuer werden so wir
gehen ganz langsam sonntag ich kann ich
gucke 3800 euro hierfür ach du scheiße
was haben wir denn noch junge 15.000
euro alter stellt euch mal vorbestellt
das dann teuer paket kommt nicht an oder
der postbote verliert das oder so was
ist er ja nicht so gut aber gut wir
hatten die drei habe ich eben überhaupt
größen brauchen hier ist ja auch egal
ja vom nehmen wir mal die größe 38 zur
auswahl hinzufügen so leute und ich
würde sagen 102 sachen machen wir noch
wir würfeln hier einmal die vier
kategorie damendüfte auf jetzt haben ein
paar für und die 10 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
die welt der düfte kommt hier auf
irgendwo mal den will ich hier der
saison
ich bin noch nicht ganz fertig aber
gleichwohl jemand von euch ein duft von
louis vitton kostet nur 3800 euro also
gut
hier kann man irgendwie nichts bestellen
doch doch doch hier die kollektion hier
gut dann wirklich einmal die 6 1 2 3 4 5
6 210 euro ja da habe ich einen
absoluten schnapper gemacht so das ding
ist dieser duft kostet in der produktion
locker nicht mehr als eine ahnung ich
kenne mich da auch nicht aus ich würde
sagen maximal 3
also ein bisschen gewinn fahren die da
schon ein ja gut komme ich würde sagen
eine sache geht noch und zwar aus der
kategorie die welt von louie vito doch
ok kommen wir haben hier die 8 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 8 die foundation
ach so dass das kann man gar nicht
kaufen da kommt dann gehen wir noch mal
in die herren haben wir die 41 hamann 13
34 kleinlederwaren und die drei 12.30
und apps also was haben sogar relativ
viele die ich kenne so ein louis vitton
portemonnaie oder etui weiß ich mal wie
teuer das ist 235 euro meine theorie
damals was ich mir geholt habe für die
schule hat glaube ich weiß ich nicht so
19 euro gekostet so und die 12 12 36 9
und 12 hirai von sieben ja passt sogar
das ist auch noch ganz cool kann man
bestimmt gut als fake bekommen
entschuldigung sie können maximal fünf
produkte im einkaufswagen scheiße gut
ich merke mir das alles klar leute wir
schauen noch mal kurz in den warenkorb
ich merke mir das natürlich alles
schreibt mir das auf wir haben hier den
koffer wir haben hier den messenger pm
die haben das klassische t shirt
connected die tempel horizon offiziers
jacke dann noch das parfum und die
iphone hülle oder was auch immer das war
und müssen dann ungefähr bei 11.300 euro
liegen 11.300 euro für sieben louis
vuitton produkte ist auf jeden fall eine
ansage ich hoffe ihr freut euch auf das
video zu den fake sachen ich weiß nicht
ob ich so mache dass ich dazu auch noch
mal ein extra video mache wie ich die
ganzen sachen suche und dann noch ein
video wenn die da sind könnt ihr gerne
in die kommentare schreiben ob ich das
machen soll
dann sehe ich ja fast nur nach oben
damals durchgefallen hat kauft bitte
nicht bei louis vuitton das ist nämlich
viel zu viel geld was ihr daraus geben
dann könnte es auch lieber mir geben und
wir sind uns dann wahrscheinlich morgen
wieder morgen gibt's neues cooles video
19 uhr ich glaube morgens freitag dann
gibt's doch schon um 14 uhr hat er jack
londons
ich gucke jetzt fußball habe ich 20
minuten verpasst wegen gibt es ja gar
nicht